the world has changed and we need heroes
insert Kylie Jenner I love it
leading up to the highly anticipated
theatrical release of Avengers endgame
Kylie Travis Scott and their
one-year-old daughter stormy dressed up
as characters from the flick the reality
star shared this sweet family pic on
Instagram
that's Kylie holding her little girl who
brace yourself for some serious cuteness
appears to be sporting a teeny-tiny red
cape yeah we're pretty sure Kylie
dressed stormy up as Doctor Strange
looking for you as for Kylie she
channeled her inner brie Larson looking
Captain Marvel chic AF and you're free a
race of noble boys heroes noble warrior
heroes and Travis he went all out to
posing as Iron Man
I think Robert Downey jr. would be proud
Kylie caption the post quote happy end
game everyone will forgive her for
smelling end game as two words okay so
after snapping some pics with stormy it
was time for mom and dad to have a kid
free and kind of sexy photo shoot in
their get-ups the 21 year old captioned
these superhero super hot shots oh you
didn't catch iron flame and Captain
lipcott in the credits sucks for you
you're probably wondering why Kylie and
company got in full costume on a random
Thursday right it's just so crazy well
it was all to celebrate the rapper's
28th birthday baby okay Kylie threw a
bash for her man a few days early at a
theater that screened the movie The
Beauty moguls famous fam was in
attendance including Kris Khloe Kourtney
Kim and Kanye Kim and Kanye did what Kim
and Kanye do making the night a fashion
moment
Kim turned heads and a pair of skin
tight red latex pants a maroon
off-the-shoulder crop top and sky-high
heels complete with a grey hoodie and
there's Kanye in a maroon sweatshirt
purple tee matching pants and black
sneakers of course it wouldn't be a
birthday party without a cake and some
balloons and Kylie went all out both
reading happy birthday husband now
before you go and get all crazy thinking
Kylie and Travis are married that's just
what they call each other at least
according to Kim they call each other
husband and wife are they married
engaged what's the situation
you know I'm literally need to ask her
that is gonna be my next question on our
group chat we were chatting on the way
over here and I think we just saw think
like that's like you know what they call
each other okay so back to Kylie in
Travis's cosplay moment
actually isn't the first time that these
two have gotten in theme for a major pop
culture moment earlier this month Travis
was so excited for the premiere of Game
of Thrones that he shared these picks
with the caption house of flames son of
Lord Shakti Webster the first husband of
the goddess Kay protector of the Seven
Kingdoms Blatt Kiley and Travis are
total couple goals and this whole family
photo shoot gave me major incredibles
vibes of course we'll be here to keep
you up to date on all things Kiley and
Travis so be sure to keep it locked on
ET until next time I'm Hallie Stevens
bye for now
[Music]